how do you get to reading more than a
million words a year in the language
you're learning is that even possible
the average person reads 14 15 books a
year little more than one a month this
works out to a little over a million
words a year just in terms of books but
of course we read all kinds of other
stuff newspaper articles online Twitter
Facebook so we easily read more than a
million words a year in our own language
but obviously it's much more difficult
to read in the language we're learning
especially if the writing system is
different one key to reading success is
that the content be of interest you read
things that you enjoy listen to the same
content when reading away from the
computer ignore the words you don't know
because looking up words very much slows
you down if you are dedicated to one
language and you genuinely want to
become fluent in that language the goal
of reading a million words a year is
attainable and there will be many
benefits across your language skills